me
Maple tempura is a traditional sweet that
dates back to 1300 years,
but it's only made into sweets.
[Music] My
name is Setsuko in my last work.
It's been 50 years since I've been pouring mart into it.
[Music]
Booby degree a Platy autumn leaves Here's autumn leaves
like this.
It's
40 tempura that you pull out the batter to make a batter and then raise it.
[Music]
You say that the maple tempura is sometimes eaten raw, but it's seasoned at all.
Because it contains sugar
, it's sweetened. It's
handmade one by one. It's a hassle to arrange it again after a little sprinkling
.
It's been a year, but the
maple tempura is fun to make, and I'm particular about it
. There are many customers who don't really know about the rainbow tempura.
I'm so happy
ni
me
[music]